this week conflict zone is in Paris to
meet Karina rasigan Speaker of the
French Socialist Party the socialist
candidate is poised for a crushing
defeat at the ballot in late April is
this the end of the French Socialist
Party
[Music]
Kohinoor a cigar welcome to conflict
zone the Socialists came to power
promising change you promise to reduce
the gap between the poor and the rich
you didn't deliver that's not true we
did inherit a very difficult situation
and we did have to first try to reduce
the budget crisis and and reinvigorate
our industry so this this necessitated
reforms that were long-term reforms but
we did reduce poverty we did increase
all of the social welfare minimums what
we have to see is that we have contrary
to Germany for example we have a
population that is increasing in
demography right we have many more
hundreds of thousands of young people
who were on the on the job market every
year and and you have young people who
are doing well no because the demography
is increasing which means that in order
to reduce to reduce unemployment rate
the unemployment rate we have to create
a lot more jobs than for example in
Germany because in Germany you have a
respite or a job might be a very
interesting way to sell play to failure
so let us speak about it is let me speak
about the other one
it is satisfactory we are not satisfied
with the results I'm not saying we're
satisfied with the results I'm saying
that it was a very difficult situation
that there are still a lot more things
that we can do but you promised but you
promised to the French people no we are
really honest that we are taking over
the government we will reduce
unemployment under along unemployment
has stayed above 10 percent I mean this
is a failure we did produce
poverty gap that is that is a fact and
we also worked at rebuilding our
industry and these are results that
unfortunately will take years to show
but we so it is a very objective if you
want to talk about failure there is a
failure unemployment but when it when it
comes to when it comes to rebuilding the
foundation about when it comes to
rebuilding with the foundation of our
economy so that we can reduce
unemployment in the future in the next
few years I think the next president
expects president will benefit from the
reforms that was the expectation this is
not proved again or not became the first
socialist power in 17 years and when I
remember the campaign unemployment was
one of the most critical issues and
nothing changed no you cannot say that
nothing changed because you can see the
trend is different we did see the reason
why the reason why the employment rate
is about the same now as it was five
years ago is because it did increase
during the first couple years son
and then the employment rate did
increase during the first couple of
years but for the last about a year and
a half to two years we've had a job
creation that is higher than job loss
which is which is a switch in the in the
trend and so what we're seeing now is
where we've engaged friends on the
trends to towards unemployment rate
going down towards job creation
increasing which change the trends that
we were in for the the the 10 the
previous 10 years about another trend
one of the highest unemployment is in
the born user suburbs like in Paris
where in some places it is set about 40
percent one lost generation after the
other
even when socialists are in government
this is where this situation was the
worst to begin with it's still 40
percent and it is
it is the the the situation also in in
other seas territories is also very
something yes 40% unemployment a young
generation yes a lost generation this is
not one no well this is why we've also
put a lot of effort into our policies
for the suburbs for the cities but this
also the problem is today we have we
have expectations that are very high
which is normal but on a very short term
and unfortunately sometimes when the
situation is so difficult the the
policies that we need to conduct our
long term policies that cannot produce
results within a few years and it's true
that probably we set the expectations
too high but I think I believe a student
we have we've invested a lot in a suburb
invest in education we've invested a lot
in in in professional training not
enough I understand your argument you're
saying we need more time yes but I'm
telling you you didn't do enough didn't
you did you enough I mean it's only 40
percent now they change the structures
didn't change in the born use the
problems didn't change the conflicts
didn't change the violence didn't change
and you are the Left party with
integration Kay and I cannot say are you
saying that nothing changed the probably
things didn't change fast enough
certainly but you cannot say that
nothing changed so what is any not
enough and nothing changed we impulse
changes that are taking time to produce
those results and it's in the suburbs
the the problem is very complex you
cannot act on one single on one single
lever it's otherwise people would have
solved the problem long ago this is a
result is a ssin time in France and that
nobody really took this as serious and
it has plan I think it's
it's true that we have been lacking over
the year for the decades in France in
general I'm not saying left or right I
think the government went after the the
government's went after the other we've
been with we've been lacking in our
attention to the integration issues with
the second third generation of
immigration is physical post
colonization because I think contrary to
other waves of immigration in in the
past in France from coming from Europe
with understimated the issue of racism
you didn't care what does no estimation
all these problems were viewed every day
you had no modules and you knew you knew
what was going on no because well of
course we knew what was going on but the
root of your problem is much more
complex than for example the integration
of in the past of Spanish immigrants or
Italian immigrants immigrants these were
French people from York but the problem
is because there is still an ingrained
problem of racism in the country that we
did not want to see which we can see now
with the rise of the four national for
example is also successful twenty
fifteen years ago in the presidential
it's not the first time is helping the
candidate from the phone arsenal to be a
candidate for the presidency in the
first way well when when jean-marie Le
Pen got to the second round of the
election in 2002 it was a shock to
everyone today it's not a shock that the
finesse in that is so high this is what
has changed in the country this is very
different they are in very different
situation and we can see this rise of
xenophobia and racism and populism and
nationalism in other countries a lot of
these young people we are speaking about
are French Muslims did you fail in the
integration I think yeah
I will say that I will concede that this
is this is a this is an area where the
question of how we treat Islam in the
country has been an issue and because
and this is this is also this has
compounded a problem in the suburbs
including the the economic problems in
the suburbs because with 10 because also
we've had a far-right and and the
right-wing party mistakes tell me some
of the biggest mistakes and France
towards them well for example for
example I think we did not do enough
after the first time that we were
touched by terrorism Islamist jihadist
terrorism in the nineties in France we
did not do enough after that to make
sure that Islam is fully integrated in
the country as a normal religion but it
was not as poor this didn't happen with
the terror act Islam was not enough
integrated in France before yes but I
mean I'm not going to talk about the 70s
and the ADA was right phases you will
have better few um I think what other
measure I think we we have been working
dark as never has been very good at when
it was Minister of the Interior and now
Prime Minister as working as working
with the Muslim community in France at
towards recognizing an Islam of France
and and recognizing what Islam means in
this country what the Muslim culture has
brought to this country and making sure
that with enough Republican framework of
lazy day of secularism French secularism
believe me that Islam finds it hides its
place let me quote as a ray the
spokeswoman for the collective against
Islamophobia in France she accused your
party the Socialist Party the government
your government emphasizes on the fact
that Islam is the problem and Muslim
people do not respect the Republic and
its values its
system of creating a state god for the
society Elsa ray is accusing the
Socialist Party and the Socialists gone
I know laying with races I ain't kidding
I know these collects it very well they
have a definition they tend to there are
also they can sometimes be part of the
problem because sometimes they how
should I put this they exaggerate some
of the some of the issues because they
like to exist immediately with these
type of because you know this criticism
I'm talking about this collective
specifically right this I I knew how
they function and they have a definition
of secularism which is not the French
definition of secularism they want they
want to want to move friends towards a
relationship between politics and
between the state and religion that is
closer to what we see in the United
States which is a country very well and
so it's um there are they are trying to
create community community terrorism
around the Muslim religion okay in
France so they're not very like let me
let me quote somebody else an important
French politician said quote Islam is
certainly a problem it is dangerous not
itself but when it wants to affirm
itself as a religion in the Republic it
could be a problem where the Muslims
behave in an anti Republican manner who
do you think made this remark Salam is
certainly a problem no it's your
president yes okay it's loose you know
yes do you think that this helps an
integration credibility and yeah I think
even Muslim a lot of French people of
Muslim culture or Muslim faiths are
saying this too right because we have a
very strict definition of what
separation of church of religion and
state is in France we have a very strict
definition of lay City and I was very
hard on the cat
when they were against when they were
against gay marriage and trying to use
religious arguments in the political
debate and for the same reason I can be
very strong also on on on Muslim people
Muslim French people who are trying to
change the law to to make it conform to
Islamic rule that cannot by the Roman
Catholics we talked about Muslims there
are some more groups in France but
President or not that perhaps a result
of all of that has now a seventy percent
disapproval rate and only four percent
say that they are satisfied with the
president's performance it can't get any
worse for a politician and his party I
think history will I also I don't is not
candidate for the for the I represent
the Socialist Party yes but can't get
and you were also for a party you can it
is where after the polls of this week
around eight percent
he's even not to call it a negligible
anymore in this campaign well well I
think we'll see what the Socialist Party
does in the parliamentary election yes
we did yes around eight percent I mean
he's out of the game and the president
is socialist the government is a
socialist one I mean it can't get any
worse we are in very bad situation yes
it's true but I think this is a problem
for most a lot of old parties and
governing parties in France today we're
going through political crisis and we do
have to reinvent ourselves we will have
to reinvent ourselves after the election
I think I think we are in a very
specific time we are in a very unusual
time and I think this this this election
reflects that I think this is a very
crazy election this is for the very
first time it's possible that none of
the major parties will have
candidate made your left right or left
wing or right we have another one the
social animal is less popular than the
Faunus you know in 2012 the socialist
one with 51 percent of the votes and now
you cannot even reach 10 percent
according to the post this is an
admission of failure no party will have
a majority in France for for very long
time I think so we do have we do have a
problem with the left in general which
is very fractured the left has not a
problem there is a candidate generally
weak made on so he is the representative
but it's other types with left I think
he's a it has a very charismatic person
whose whose is true capturing right now
and electorate that and including a
socialist electorate that's a little
lost right now but I'm not sure that
only long run and especially with the
parliamentary election that we will see
the same level for jean-luc may not
short because I think it's this person
that attracts if you remove jean-luc
Minoso from this party there's nothing
left
if you remove whatever is at the head of
the party today people still know where
the Socialists are people doesn't
believe there's something I
I just told you we do have to reinvent
ourselves I think and but we can't do
this without usually advantage we have
to read with you a few time we have many
years we have very left from the
beginning 75% income taxes then you
changed again that's not true
I mean if you if you the seventy five
percent tax measure was the real the
only really radical left measure that
was proposed and done by our own if you
look at his hat is a platform in 2012 it
was a very social democratic platform it
was a very centralized platform and this
is how it governs us this is how he
governs in February of 2016 the
socialist government
attempted and ultimately failed a reform
of the Labor Code the reform in its
original draft included easier way for
companies to fire workers reduction in
overtime payment and reduction of
severance packages I mean this isn't
that this is this is this is a flawed
interpretation of what was in the law
and this is not was what's voted at the
end okay so I would bet I will ask ah
did you decide did you decide that it
will be easier than it was before to
fire workers yes or not yes or not no no
overtime payment yes or no it was about
the possibility of doing this in in
social negotiations which is in in the
end at the level of the other person
possible before it was possible before
no it was already possible before it was
already this will be it's over today was
a pretty possible bit before with a 30
percent union vote and we wanted to put
at the branch level and we wanted to
push it to 50 percent union vote at the
enterprise level so it was already
possible before it we just made it we
just increase the the the the capacity
of the unions in your intervening and
making this what about the reduction
overtime payment this is less policy and
what so this is what I'm talking about
about about overtime and about overtime
payment the negotiation we wanted them
to be at the level of the company at the
level of the Enterprise Center and
Julian French people protested against
these measures yes or not and Prime
Minister was seemed not to be impressed
by it and they accuse you that this is
not anymore left I think I think I will
stand by the fact that these are social
democratic reforms this is a social
democratic reform this was about the
Social Democrats I am both you are now
boast but five years I believe yes also
said he's a social democrat Snyder oh
well if you want to make that pear
if I ask you I think no I think it's a
different time and it's a different
country and then it's but there are
similarities in the sense that I think
France where alone made a lot of reforms
that we're very hard to make that we're
very popular it's true
maybe because also we weren't very good
at explaining them and negotiating them
upfront that's true but I think just
like ok America has benefited a lot from
the reforms that sugar put in put in
place in Germany I think when whoever is
the next president will benefit a lot
from the reforms that's also around all
these different forms were rain through
the National Assembly against the wishes
of the opposition and many of your own
representatives and Senators was this
the beginning of the end of your party
you obliged the country to accept
something that the majority didn't want
to have actually I think if you if you
look at if you look at the detail of
what we've done if you if you ask people
in the polls measure by measure most of
the time they agree with what we've done
if we don't tell us that if we don't
tell them that that's what we've done so
there's been some level of irrationality
in how this is this no because the
results were not visible and I
understand that 75% of French who found
the maneuvers shocking you didn't have
the majority for all that you have
disappointed your voters we have
disappointed the voters that's true
that's true because the because people
don't feel the results in their daily
lives strongly enough I think is this
changing a little bit now I think people
are starting to see some improvements
and we'll see what they say a little in
a few months I think possibly especially
when we see what's happening in the
presidential election right now and who
may come out of it I can i I would take
the bet that Francois long will be the
a very regretted president in the very
in in the just a short few but let's
speak about another example of this
president or not and his credibility in
2012 he said that the financial sector
was his main enemy but when Britain
chose to leave the EU he was quick to
offer the bank's tax breaks to attract
some of them to come Paris from London
yes what the Apocrypha if the financial
sector is the main enemy while always
invites the financial and say coming to
my country my main enemy that's not what
he said he said he said the the faceless
financial sector afraid the one that
speculates the one that it was
responsible for the 2008 financial
crisis but we do need finances obviously
who is going to financial ah these
bankers these banks yes and we have them
yes but we've worked at separating high
risk speculating finance from regular
banking right this is what the issue was
really is the fact that normal people
were paying for high-risk speculators
when they make mistakes and so we
separated the activities of highly
speculative finance financers from the
normal banking system we've also done
that we've also worked at doing that at
the European level with the with the
banking Union directive what is and and
we do obviously we do need to have a
place where we can trade what is your
feeling yes if you take in consideration
France 2017 on astronaut in the pan
third of the voters once - yes and I
think even not anymore 10% for your
party what changed in France well I said
just as I said before I think we've
we've seen a rise in in populism in
simplistic ideas in in in nationalism in
France just like we've seen it in other
European country so they think this is
and we've seen it in the United States
we don't have time selection so this is
I think a reflection that all of the
Democratic parties must have and and I
think the left has fractured in France
and this is a very worrying that we have
to find a way to unite the left again
and we do have to find a way to reinvent
convener estiga thank you very much for
being on conflict so thank you very much
[Music]